[Music]
all right
welcome to ash wednesday here we haven't
done one of these in a while but uh
really excited uh to have my guests on
first i should mention not an official
sponsoring to the show but if you go to
cigarsdaily.com enter the promo code
crowder you get 15 off
this oliva milano it's a smaller cigar
and they sell them in boxes of 10. so
just a buddy of mine good guy it's
really nice help me actually after the
surgery with some stuff cigars daily.com
enter in the promo code uh not a sponsor
youtube and we have here really excited
actually uh i've been watching for a
long time i've watched one of his sets
gosh i want to say back in
might have been 96 at the just for
laughs in montreal so i grew up watching
him um and uh really admiring a lot of
his stand up and then dave is friends
with him you can listen to his podcast
bruniverse and then his special which is
killing it on youtube millions of plays
someone had to say it
i think i hit all the plugs out jim
brewer how you doing brother i'm good
man thanks for having me oh i'm glad to
have you yeah i uh i was i know dave had
been on your show yeah and uh i like i
told you i grew up watching right was it
96 or 97 you must have done it just for
laughs at that point yeah i think i
think i did 96 maybe 96.97 i want to say
kevin james might have been the host
that makes sense yeah because i remember
seeing him before he got king of queens
and i watched the set that got ray
romano his show and released a scout at
the just for last 98
and the only reason i know that dave is
because
i was in new york and i was doing the
comic strip i always i used to have to
follow ray romano
and so ray would go out and i had a show
they were developing and on their feet i
went up to ray i'm like race well you
know i need to i need a big time writer
and your material is good if you would
like to be the writer
he went i kind of got this thing they're
working on i went yeah
good luck with that
good luck the biggest sitcom of the
decade
ever and mine went it's still looking
for it did you offer larry david to
shine your shoes
um was that for you so it's right around
there
what was that for the you and chappelle
the sitcom
no that was before that's right it was
actually before that yeah okay yeah
right before so that was like 94-ish
okay
and for people who are on and i don't
think a lot of them are but maybe
they're not as intensely familiar with
you like obviously stand-up comedy
people have probably seen you right in
uh in half-baked and you've seen your
stuff on tv but now you've been in the
news a little bit lately just for
stances that are seeing someone's
contract you you know chose to do shows
where they didn't have the vaccine right
deal and then next thing you know you're
in the news which you're not a news guy
no i'm not a news guy at all in fact but
this is why i'm glad i'm at a point in
life where i don't check messages i
don't if i make a video i put up i don't
when i made that video and i said i'm
not performing
any venues that forced the vax card and
that that came from fans there were
already gigs booked right and then the
venues said no you got to show up your
card and all i did was make my video i
mentioned you know morals i believe in
this i've gone in my life there's a
thing i'd rather play whatever i said
and then i just left it and then i had
no clue it was going to turn into
what it turned into yeah i had
zero clue what was what was the fallout
like like a lot of supporters but i was
on the flip side yes so
i won't mention the name
huge comedian calls me
as soon as i'm done with the video and i
knew right away i'm like
you know what
i'm gonna record this
oh man
was it bill
burr he's not gonna oh did i just you
just dude you can't not do shows the
[ __ ] vaccine you're gonna get out of
your [ __ ] mind dude
i know what you're thinking i don't want
you
oh my god
right i
i'm sorry we'll just bleep that this is
what
not enough then the impression i didn't
say it was i didn't say it was she
didn't i'm more impressed by your
impression i had nicked apollo call me
furious because we had him on a podcast
one time and on that that was the same
show on youtube right did bob ross
painting muhammad
yeah and i just got a call nick depaul
i'm like okay i was driving i got put it
down and then i got a second call nick
apollo and i never hear from him he's a
kind of a recluse and i pick up his are
you out of your mind you got me next to
muhammad on that and he's just going
nuts i'm like nick apollo is nervous
about this and it's just it's weird what
gets people well comfortable that would
be one of the things that should yeah it
makes sense yes i mean i don't want to
be i i don't know
[Laughter]
i didn't uh
yeah so yeah i i got a call from someone
and i i gotta say i was a little i was a
little shocked
yeah that where they where they were
coming from and i just tell my stance
i'm like no man i'm telling you and then
we got a little intense
with the conversation he was talking
about vaccines like hey man not for
nothing but i know for a fact
fact
uh some people very close to my life
that have been affected of course uh not
from what just came out but from the
past right uh we're talking about
paralyzed at five years old and it took
a year and a half too so why do you tell
them yeah that's all nonsense i want you
tell this kid so
yes there was feedback uh i lost some
gigs right that i had i also had the
special
the the somebody had to say it it was
going to air on a platform where dude my
following at the time was like 40 50.
i i i don't know how to download i just
want to press i want to see jim special
hit here but did you say you don't know
how to download things i do okay
but it's just
i don't want to do it it takes a minute
it does take a while it's annoying
especially if it's in the cloud i don't
fully understand it yeah yeah so so um
yeah so
the whole then the special was dropped
yeah um and so whatever so yes but i
don't care was the special drop from us
not to sorry interrupt but what was it a
special drop from an actual uh streaming
service yes can i see can you say which
one or no
i i honestly don't
um you don't know if you can go straight
it doesn't matter oh it doesn't matter
because i'm just wondering because
there's been a few instances of that now
where i find it so ridiculous it doesn't
matter
like andrew schultz yeah well he bought
his bag he brought his back yeah where
was it in netflix right
now yeah amazon they said we need you to
cut all this stuff that involved biden
and he was like no
so he bought it back from
amazon and then aired it all out which
is so funny because he's a comedy witch
hunt i mean biden like for crying out
loud regardless of politics you'd think
people would admit okay this is fodder
for comedy it was all the cruelty if he
got lost in his front yard you know what
i mean stuff like that where the fact
that you can't even eat this is the
biggest comedy gold in history
is this administration how are you not
saying anything and then
if you say something how do you not
realize
we are in the middle of
you will not speak of the following
peoples if you're crying out loud half
the daily show dined out and george w
bush pronouncing it nuclear for years
[ __ ] his pants with the pope
america i get it i get it too but nobody
is allowed to touch this administration
you will not even discuss
from the vice president
former vice president yeah respect the
office for yeah no even her
okay you brought that up your audience
so because some people are watching
right now and dave had to do that too by
the way with the vaccine uh you did
cancel some shows uh yeah a couple of
them it was just i didn't stop traveling
and i'm a huge germaphobe i grew up we
talked about that it's like my mom was a
nurse and i came from you know with my
dad and everything but it didn't make
sense so i was like well until you make
it make sense as a giant germaphobe i
was like i'm just gonna keep going so i
guess i'm just going to buy being a
germaphobe in detroit yeah oh yes
and harlem
i was going from detroit to harlem not
afraid of
do you know how weird that is
every comfort zone dude i would just get
on planes and it'd be like camera crews
going to report and me getting bumped to
first class because no one was on the
plane nobody was on it yeah and i was
like this is great i hope nobody ever
goes out again yeah
it was amazing
it really then you saw fuel price i mean
we started here at this uh idea here um
i came in to the with the employees and
i said look
just so you know if you want to stay
home that's fine they're doing the
quarantine uh dls if you want to stay
home that's fine i'll pay for as long as
i can
i'm not going to i'm going to show up if
i need to pare down the show and i said
by the way we're going to we're going to
be doing two a days so we did the
quarantine month and then i went to two
shows a day because i knew people were
locked up at home right and the numbers
that we saw during that time that was
kind of the shift with this company we
went from maybe having 30 40 000 people
watching live at that you know any given
second
to 150 because people were locked in at
home and it's just to me i kind of
thought like well i'm sort of surprised
that i'm one of the few people
doing this when
big names in the industry you would
think would understand their job is to
serve people
not themselves and a lot of art becomes
self-important but i wanted to get into
you mentioned your audience like 40 50
uh a lot of them a lot of people are
familiar with you from like half baked
right
half-baked right it's too easy but it's
like a christian family man
is that tough to
shed a little bit like do people come up
and like
do the do the thing where you smoke the
joint
no no but i will say this i remember
there was a period of my life
uh
probably early 2000s where
i'm selling out because i have baked and
they're throwing pot on the stage
but i also found myself trying to
appease an audience and ride that wave
and make that money and that started
getting very exhausting i can imagine
very exhausting i can't i couldn't hold
up hey man i'm not that guy
it's a character right
at the end of the day it was a character
i i never even listened to grateful dead
right
i can't so
um you just have that northern european
the bags under your eyes like i do okay
and then it's just so people like oh he
must be uh he must be on edibles but
also just my genetics i also have
heavy eyelids
and i do have what did you weigh them
how do you weigh eyelids i have no i've
never heard of that have you heard of it
meaning
uh a compliment is female will say you
have bedroom eyes i no i have sleepy
eyes and i didn't realize
this look the judgment of people until
about eighth grade
sorry i'm just realizing so funny that
is it's like such a backhanded yeah
bedroom eyes i mean not wife eyes yeah
like they're very tired
i would hear that from like older women
i don't know what was going like he's
got a bedroom you have temporary
relationship eyes yes
you have you need to sit in an upright
chair
vicks vaporub
every two hours no okay so you had these
people coming in and you felt like you
had to live up to that a little bit yeah
yeah and it was great i'm not gonna lie
it was great it was a great run i'd do a
little i'd bring my friends
on the road with me and there were
musicians we make up little pot songs um
and it was it was awesome but i so you
definitely played into it if you were
writing oh that's out without a doubt i
smoked my bun today
i did mine yesterday that's why
you know yeah so
um
you went home and drank kale
so i didn't yeah it definitely was um
i've always been a god guy right
and i've always been so that
and i had family and close friends
coming to me going
[Music]
do you want to be the pop guy
like is this the direction and it also
had other movies like harold the the
coomer and oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
that was basically hey we want you to be
in this
i do all pot movies man
it's okay we got a no talent cal pen
we'll put him in there
i don't know the guy or whatever no no
you're nice yeah no that that definitely
um
you're funnier than cal pen let's just
agree on boy thank you um
another backhanded compliment bedroom
eyes you're funnier than cal pen
gallagher's got nothing on you sir yeah
although i did work with gallagher ii oh
oh calgary
a slightly smaller couch yes it's just
the same thing but in comedy clubs right
not theaters clubs you know he went nuts
gallagher he got all these patents and
these inventions have you ever heard him
talk he had like 500 patents and like i
have a shower where you go and it
automatically turns on the water you're
like i saw that in sky mall gallagher
that's not a he's just selling giant
bowling pins to pay for those patents
but did he want a huge couch lily
tomlins like maybe yeah maybe
do you have a big phone so i can be a
big operator
okay so people said to you they're like
do you want to be the pot guy and did
that did you and it did resonate me i'm
like you know what
yeah you're right and actually thing
when things really changed for me
standard wise and everything was it was
2008 i would go to this bar
in town chester new jersey was a little
country town middle of nowhere and um
there was a we would do dad's night out
so a couple dads in town
and we went there drinking we're hanging
out and then all of a sudden a woman
goes
oh you're the you're the you're the
famous guy in town and i always try to
down like nah nah i'm just a regular
like no you're you're
but you're like blue you're like the
drug and blue guy like like i can't
bring my kids to you because you you're
filthy yeah
and i went what i got so pissed at her
and i said what'd you say
i said did you ever see me live right
she went no but i i just i mean everyone
knows it and that was that was a
defining moment
instead of being mad at her
i thought
well how many other people feel this way
and think that way about me
really at the end of the day i'm a
family guy yeah i'm a moral guy i'm a
guy what
why do people feel and think that way
about me because of the movie because it
isn't it and that was the moment when
you know what i'm doing i'm doing my own
thing and it's gonna take time but i'm
gonna start talking about being a family
guy and i'm gonna start
showing you how i
care about family and life and god and
morals and stuff like that and that was
the beginning it was a lot of fear based
too sure because ironically that's more
taboo than just being the stoner comic
you know there aren't many comics doing
what you're talking about now i mean
outside of there are people like label
themselves christian comics or you know
that aren't really kind of but
it's more taboo to talk about family and
god than it is like i smoked
it which is bizarre be honest
we'll know that because people
immediately put you in a lump sum right
if you like i had someone uh
was it last night when now two nights
ago
yeah two nights ago
uh came to see me at a show
old time comic
um he's like hey my name is a couple
years old emmy
he came in he talked about his horrible
time in life and blah blah blah and he
goes you know you look great and the
stuff you're doing is amazing like what
you're not like all religious and stuff
right
but that persona right like if you just
say no you know i got
i do believe in this and immediately
it's like politics it's like any
category oh you're this right you're out
yeah like you don't even there's there's
everything's been categorized so it
there definitely was a fear in me steve
where i'm like oh my god how am i gonna
am i gonna lose this whole thing and
that that lasted all the way until
um
covid right and then i started putting
out little instagram videos
you just decided and i was no i realized
hey
we don't have control over our lives
whether we think we do or don't
right you know you can lose your child
diagnose with whatever whatever the
scenario that makes that snaps you into
reality worked out by a 14 year old if
you're cat williams
remember that that'll that'll snap you
back into it i'll snap you right back as
a reality check um
and i went if if one or two people
can see things differently on a higher
level
than so be it because it's game time now
not only am i not in control but now
we're not even in control of who decides
how we're gonna work where you're gonna
work what we're gonna take away what
we're gonna censor
how we're gonna control
your life right you never realized you
knew you were a slave but you didn't
realize you were a slave until this
showed up and that's i'm like oh wow
yeah it's it's life game time i never
thought i'd see this in my life but it's
game time so if you're gonna protect you
from destiny and it doesn't make any
sense
say it again dave you're protecting
someone from destiny from being able to
do anything correct i mean like it
doesn't make any sense to me zero sense
the rapper
yeah those are great lyrics destiny's
child
yeah
but that's what it was so it's like
you're going to take away anybody's
ability to be able to make a living
fulfill anything or do anything with
their life when anything could happen
and that's what i hated about it based
on a vaccine where my entire life it's
like i took every vaccine because my my
mom wanted me to and they all had you
know they all worked you know i do bits
even in my stand up where it's like yeah
if polio came out and everybody had
noodly legs and was fdr and all over the
house right you'd be like these don't
work too well do they but now people
keep getting covered and it's like well
you you could have got maybe your one
leg works that's pretty good if you got
the fifth you'd have gotten the fifth
booster yeah maybe you just called greg
abbott right it's a that's the deal
which blows my mind because there was
there was we had a group of friends in
new jersey we would do coffee every day
and there was one guy that would always
say well
i
i've been i get all my shots and i'm
just saying i'm the only one that hasn't
got it and he would continue to say this
one and i'd always just keep quiet well
guess who got it and he got it worse
than anyone else he's four shots in
boosters and all that right and then i
would never say
so right you know that's a little weird
and that that is uh yeah i mean it's and
you don't want to you know just point to
the anecdotal in if it flies in the face
of the empirical but in this case it
doesn't and you also have you know
bodily autonomy or at least you're
supposed to right and i think people
just label you anti-vaxx if you say i
don't know that this is as effective as
other and it's not a vaccine you're
talking about an mrna augmentation
effectively it's not an inoculation they
change the definition and just to ask
the question and does it bother i want
you to go because i can see the wheels
turning in the in the sleepy eyes but uh
but bedroom
comics should be the ones at the
forefront this is a very clearly
it's a freedom issue that comics used to
be at the forefront of it now they're
silent
well
i don't care about other comics
i realized a long time ago me trying to
appease other comedians they're not the
ones paying for my bills they're not the
ones paying to come see me right so
so peers that means nothing to me the
cool kids club that is that their that's
their club they can enjoy it they can
make their phone calls to me and and
spew whatever they think is real that's
your that's your deal brother right that
ain't mine
um so
but i will say this you're incredibly
respected by that community too so in
other words if a big name comic called
you like i remember hearing jim norton
just talk about you know what a great
story tell you where your name always
comes up whenever we even have someone
on the show
even if you're not looking to you're not
seeking their approval but that's why i
think you someone like you is so
important because it's very easy for
them to dismiss and up and come or go
they're not one of us it's very clear
you're at that top tier
and you're off the reservation as far as
things that are permissible to say well
i just go on what i what i feel
what i
what i'm observing and from what i
observed i i was
i truly to this day feel like that was
the greatest voodoo trick in human
history there's been
amazing voodoo tricks and they still
continue
but um i knew
or i
i felt
this has to be put out how is nobody
touching this and i'll tell you why
fear
fear is the most powerful tool in the
world right that is why
uh the mass media hollywood all of them
they're all fearing they're like i may
lose my job or i may not get money or i
may not do that so i lose gigs wouldn't
you rat i sleep a lot better at night
knowing what i did
rather than
oh you know what maybe i should
i had a huge gig lined up huge gig
arenas
with other and they were like hey man
you gotta you gotta and i went
i love how all of this is distilled too
yeah yeah
at the end of the day it's right hey you
want to go to a ball game yeah
oh thank you right yeah i mean how do
you not see the lunacy in that right how
do you not see the lunacy that they
brought us to
you're a seal at
a at a sea world show
you want you want some education you do
okay
okay now you can have it what so anyway
i'm getting off track here no it's okay
you're just hoping that instead of a
seal it ends up like the killer whale
and black fish where you ever see that
where the trainer is screwing with it
and then the killer whale
slowly takes the guy to the bottom and
just pins him yeah the guy has a
ponytail and deserves it yes it was
steven seagal i train
i've been doing it for 30 years welcome
to seagull world
he was the orca or yeah cause him a fish
no but it's it's it is it's true and
you're not even and before youtube gets
mad at this because we always have to
understand what their rules are even
though they're supposed to be a yes a
platform not a publisher none of this is
an anti-vaccine
saying that people should have the right
to make their decisions for their own
body and it's crazy that that was seen
as like you were the you know the second
coming of hitler from some people i've
never i could not believe
this
you know and people would say listen
uh
my wife has had you have to flip sorry
he just he's fascinated by the letter
look at the other way this way no no
don't look i'll do it for you well i've
never seen nothing like that
dave you never
know i was a drug addict i didn't use
these lighters oh i'm not gonna light it
for you like yes you are you seriously
never like i'm gonna make you do this
that's a huge power boost
oh that's like that's like john wayne
cowboy movie lighter yeah next thing you
know he's going to walk like a homo and
everyone will ignore it and act like
he's a badass yeah i used to love him
john wayne walk i was like how do people
not realize that's so gay oh john wayne
was gay was he i think so i i i listen
hollywood everyone suspect everyone's
suspect
to me everyone's on the list
yeah the guys the guy said pretty
progressive things for his time and
they're like let's get rid of his
airports yes
it's unreal the
airports that you can possibly yeah it's
like i don't mind if you get rid of it
just on that right but to change the
name based on the fact that he's like i
think indian should play indians you're
like it's native american right i think
indians should play india
you saw the uh the richard pryor piece
right oh i love that is that
are you allowed to curse yeah yeah okay
he does when he goes up
he was john wayne kicked this ass
john wayne had cancer kicked this ass
had open heart surgery kicked that ass i
cancer again it was like he said get the
[ __ ] out of here
mike mike epps take notes yeah that's so
much better than mike's episode got a
hair death oh my god richard pryor was
hilarious i always wondered what he
would you know if he was around today
and still you know lucid what uh you
always wonder a lot of guys who were
sort of venerated as heroes like would
they still have been because back then
being
progressive or more liberal was seen as
sort of counterculture but today it's
the opposite you wonder if they would
have shifted with that oh no carlin
wouldn't have no dick gregory didn't
dick cracker dick gregory was i still
watch him yeah i still watch the videos
on him on instagram and all that jazz i
used to do a show with his nephew who uh
toured with him up until the day that he
died and i mean dick was incredible he
didn't like and he was like prior i
don't think that would have changed at
all no it would have been the times
changed and he evolved with it right and
i think and not to evolve to it he
evolved with it to comment on it right i
think prior would have been that same
way because prior think about how
fearless prior was right he gave away
his bill cosby style
you know at the time that he was kind of
doing the very clean i want to be on ed
sullivan sort of a thing right to go
into clubs where he would get booed and
you know attacked for his actual because
he was introducing the street
to america that had never seen it before
right so i don't think he would be
afraid to be who he is now now i don't
know how he would be handled right i
don't think carl and i would love to see
her call it because if you look at some
of the stuff carlin i i follow him on
instagram 08 right that he passed i
think so somewhere around there
um but
the things he was talking about were
where the country's at
he laid on the line back then and it's
all extremely relevant now yes like
really relevant yeah it's pretty
incredible we swam in [ __ ]
yeah it's just it's a big club and you
ain't it you and i ain't in it yep yeah
yeah i think you just i think a lot of
them didn't foresee you know because he
would say then say all that and say and
then republicans and not realize that
you have this incredible
just this authoritarian left wing today
i don't necessarily know that they
they if they didn't see it coming i
maintain that honestly the parties
haven't switched it's just people have
woken up to it they've always been
there's always been a power grab because
i've been big government democrats but
jfk is very different from like let's
say a joe biden
oh um it's been infiltrated yeah you
know the the like
i have family that's well their brains
are the same
effectively
if you were to carbon dated
but that's another thing like people
just join a team
and they're in the team
so it's like like for instance i have a
i have family members like i'm a
democrat because in 1960 you know our
union and like
1960 yeah but that that is part of
what's the madness what goes on today
it's like you have to join a team you
join the team and you stick with the
team no matter what like for instance
i'm a die-hard mets fan okay so years
ago uh two of the mets uh if he was jose
reyes and and one of the relief pitchers
they get in trouble for beating their
wives
a man named jose beat his wife
i was shocked if
my
brother did that
or my best friend did that like dude
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you right
she was barking that's when you go out
and you walk away and you call me stupid
not if you're dominican
so
with that said
i found myself going no
you don't know what you say to him he's
had a rough go at it and their culture
yeah their culture is is different than
ours so
but that's when i caught myself going
whoa
yeah
that's the power of when you join a team
your morals will go out the window just
to defend your team and that's a that's
a that's where we're at now and that's a
dangerous place it's always interesting
to me because i mentioned that but
actually one of my first managers was
dominican i don't say his name here but
uh and i remember having these
conversations and it's sort of you're
stuck between a rock and a a rock and a
hard place like
the progressive left they get there in a
ringer where they're saying okay
all cultures are equal and they're
pro-migrant of any kind and then they
have to defend the culture that a lot of
these people and i don't just mean
islamic terrorist culture i mean in
south america much more machismo
traditional gender roles and now they're
saying what's the lgbtqaip like mexican
catholic voters and it's backfiring on
them they didn't expect this well here
two little things as you said culture
every culture is there's multi cultures
you can't love lump it we went
off course we went to the whole show
egypt all right we went to egypt last
year
and went in there not know what to
expect simple little concept my wife
said
an incr uh die hard animal lover like
she said egypt's not the place for her
oh she learned
i was like she went by then i was like i
smell sh oh that's the nile why are they
torturing that animal oh no no no no no
so we're you know we're gonna go the
pyramids and you gotta get on the camel
these camels clearly
were like oh [ __ ]
there's tourists we've had no tourists
for two years i gotta carry some of my
back again we get on these i get on mine
this thing gets up it's it's got a it's
got a raw
i have the video it's raw open wound
from the top of its neck all the way
down here what it is i don't even know
and there's all flies in it i'm like oh
is this
so
my guy my guy's a little out of control
and then my wife's camel gets up and
they're both
they're not being good so if you go on a
horseback ride they're like okay you
know slow down
these guys they weren't saying listen
camel be nice they were taking sticks
hey man this is how they do it yeah so
you march over here like how do you want
to do that right you're going to march
in the just say like what do you yeah i
don't know what do you think of
mclaughlin yeah exactly
sarah mclaughlin that's what i'm saying
where is she campbell they thought that
syrian refugees were going to come in
and protest fair life milk with them
factory farming like what's the problem
you mean you get more yield screw them
the cows are [ __ ] no you're
absolutely right it really is it's like
look
and i don't want to say not all cultures
are equal meaning that inherently a
culture is better but not all cultures
are the same and certainly here in the
united states some cultures
can can be become a part of this melting
pot this mosaic more effectively than
others yeah there was a few just if you
treat animals that way
we had a place i will tell you this was
called kenny wong where i grew up on the
south shore of montreal it was
constantly getting health code
violations because they were poisoning
seagulls on the roof to them it was free
food these were first generation
migrants yeah the the orange chicken
half the time it was seagull venice
beach yeah
it was called kenny wong oh i'm sorry
for crying out loud it was just like and
it constantly was getting into trouble
and they just because in their cultures
like well look make use of what you have
which also is resourceful
but you have a bunch of angry white
[ __ ] in canada yes dude my dad used
to eat possum and turtles my dad right
here in this country he grew up in the
20s 30s and he used to tell me growing
up he'd go around possum pie
what
like i hope not is your dad from lemony
snickets
turtle soup and possum pie like where
did you grow up
that you eat possum pie
where were we as a country but you're
like a pet store i mean that was surviv
yeah but that was survived adrian's true
though like that and that's not that
long ago no yeah yeah they made use of
what they had that's right at that point
that's right so um and by the show is is
bruno versus the podcast yes uh somebody
had to say it somebody had to say it
people can watch it on youtube yes it's
killing oh yeah i know it's done
incredible but there was a little word
documentary too about your dad that i
think people should watch you know what
i should put that you really should put
that out there i should put it on
youtube yeah it was
and i swear dave the reason i did was to
put the light on him
and the light on anyone
that that has
that becomes a caretaker because that's
what it was it was it was becoming a
caretaker and it was the greatest thing
i ever got to do in my whole life
i begged god my whole life don't leave
this man alone
please don't leave this man alone
there's a million stories like him um i
looked up i looked up to my dad so much
because
ten brown sisters grew up in kentucky
dayton kentucky not dayton ohio dayton
kentucky
mom died when he was three
goes to world war ii for three years all
the brewers went to war all brewers came
back sure a little wacky
uh blessed
he never complained never [ __ ] never
moaned was there as a real man my whole
life
and uh
when i go i bring him on the road i knew
he was i knew he was dying i knew he was
getting old and all i wanted to be
i just wanted to be there for him and i
got that opportunity and i and i thank
god every day for and i got to hold him
to his last breath it was the most
incredible thing i could ever done
and uh it was uh
yeah it was phenomenal to
so that what i loved about putting that
documentary was
and lou and steve a little i didn't know
your dad was i met your dad yeah and
there's something deeper
when
i meet someone like i have a comedian
and opens for me joe sib and
joseph doesn't even realize when he came
to open for me this one time i gave him
a shot he brought his dad yeah
and he didn't realize like dude unless
they throw [ __ ] at you tonight you're
already in the fact that of all the
people you could have brought to the
show you brought your dad well you know
what and also i appreciate you saying
that because dave knows this you know uh
darren my dad first off he's been on the
show he's wickedly funny
he's i always say he's like me but
more affable like he everyone likes him
you know he's he doesn't have the
low-grade irritation that i constantly
have but he's the he's true it's true
he's been he's far more likable but he's
been the booker on the show for a long
time because we had a booker who was a
booker for the view and meredith for and
bookers just kept dropping out because
they were saying people are afraid to
book this show and so i said dad you're
a people person like do you think you
could and then you know he was getting
these big names on and people on the
left that's one of their attacks is like
oh you have your dad working for you i'm
like
yeah isn't it great it's a family
business i couldn't be more grateful and
he's a great guy so it really genuinely
doesn't bother me and i'm glad to hear
that you're you had a relationship like
that because everyone often thinks that
comics are broken in a broken family
life and household you're just funny
yeah our family life was tremendous at
the greatest childhood in the world and
my dad never and i always look i always
look at him because and the documentary
is called more than me yeah i i honestly
don't even know where you can find it
but i feel like i should just put it get
it out get it on youtube i'll go after
this people who want to see it yeah
i promise you'll put on youtube yeah it
really is something people should see
because it helps them yeah it shows and
also shows the connection you should
have with your father how if you still
have your parents
shows how important that connection is
and like how you can be there for them
so many people think it's a burden and
it's like and also somebody who doesn't
have their dad you're very lucky you
know like if you still have your dad oh
seriously thank your lucky stars because
yeah something that you
it's it's so wonderful to have your
family and it's great that your dad
books your show
no oh no dad no
whatever no dad
why don't you go call your pops up oh
yeah you can't
you definitely were a teenager probably
didn't even want you um so
[Laughter]
all i know is all i know is jeff no
don't look all i know is 22 years
all i know genuinely is if your dad
would be around today he would be
incredibly disappointed i know
that was what my mom said just before
she killed herself
sort of suicide
anyways
it said it's all your fault it was a
reverse goodwill hunter i miss your day
this is mainly you
[Laughter]
oh damn agent orange is what your dad
calls his shotgun
but no
his dad was i'd reached out to his dad
and then his dad watched my stand-up and
became a fan
so he's like i really like your comedy i
want you to me like so it's how i even
met him was because his dad was the
booker if you're going through a typical
hollywood booker i don't think i would
have met him
because it was somebody actually took
the time to be like oh yes right for the
show no he really he really cares and um
you know i will say this too i was i
don't know if it was like this with your
dad but
you know my dad was a very very high
level hockey player and he'll never talk
about it i brag on him and right now
he's probably
embarrassed if he's watching the feed uh
he was you know scholarship at u of m
and back then they only drafted
canadians and americans go to like this
kind of summer training camp and he was
picked for that for the new york rangers
but he had a dad had really discouraged
him like church hockey puck around so he
actually just didn't lie his way but
charmed his way to the corner office at
ef hutton and then dean witter and kind
of left hockey by the wayside and i
think because
he could have been so good at hockey and
he was
um and his dad discouraged him he
decided that he wasn't gonna push me
into hockey but whatever it was that i
was passionate about he would be
supportive of me and that to me is
something i'm incredibly grateful for
steve
the moment i told my parents
because i there was it was a defining
moment
um
i was i was
uh i started stand up in 85 high school
i started going to open mic yeah once in
a while and then i want to be an actor i
want to be in movies and acting and i
went to a community college and then
while i was there i'd go there and do
stand-up once more but then my family
moved to florida my parents moved to
florida i think it's a law if you grumpy
all right we work your 62. it's gonna
blur that
crush it for 10 years and die of a
stroke don't use your turn signals
right and i will be dead
if you stay in michigan the government
governor just kills you yes it's best
new york yeah
okay so they moved to florida so i moved
to florida and i finally realized after
partying blah blah searching for my life
i went you know what
i wanted to do i'm doing this and i was
so nervous and i just i just came in
front of my parents i went listen
i'm doing stand-up comedy rest of my
life i don't know what to tell you
and my mom was like oh my god my dad
said
you know what
you go do that you're young you got the
passion this man never said more than 10
words in his whole life to me right he
goes you go do that
i never had that opportunity
so you go do that and if you find
yourself 30 years old and you didn't
make it hey
whatever you'll find a job he goes go do
it and that's all i needed yeah that's
all
i needed and that that was the beginning
of it oh yes uh that a father is
extremely powerful
as a man
in in in a in
raising a child and now we diminish it
and just sort of we we consider the
patriarchy as though it's a bad thing
like i understand if patriarchy means
that women are second-class citizens
like saudi arabia but patriarchy meaning
that you need a a strong father figure
that can shake or break somebody
absolutely we've taken beautiful things
and turned them into ugly things that's
what we've done a lot that's an agenda
yeah listen
when i was when i was down dancing
around the hollywood scene
every single executive abc nbc
every single one of them cbs
um
i saw them when they walked in the room
the decision makers
let's just say they weren't really
family men no and they really were
pushing
uh
a different agenda yeah for what i
wanted to put out there and that's when
i that's i mean that's when i realized
too this isn't just television this goes
into magazines and everything else who
runs the show
who makes the decisions they're all
angry
anti-family
uh anti-moral
anti-faith people right and it is
staggering and you know i would i would
tell friends and all that oh you just
joe you just pissed cause you didn't get
it
like no but you did though
i did you did you did my own i got
everything i wanted you're a comedian
who was on snl and look again it doesn't
get any higher than that i i got
everything what i want to do right you
know i mean not today but back then well
yeah yeah when you're on with yeah
colin and norm and not today when you're
next to members of the amazing by the
way norm is crazy i love your story
about okay hold on but i don't want to
get back to you but i love your story
about norm with chris kattan oh can you
tell that one of course i can okay for
people who don't know if you haven't
seen he's told it before but you may not
be familiar with chris i apologize now
it's just one of those stories i feel
bad for chris now but i it it it's one
of those
so
rod serling norm would
here i'll tell you i i'll just so that
make him work i norm like i said i got
to watch all the the the sets at the
gala at the saint andy theater my mom
was did wardrobe in costumes for the
just for laughs norm was when i decided
i wanted to do stand-up comedy i started
writing standup at
13 or 14 but it was because norm did a
joke and i still remember to this day
was 1993 maybe 94
and it was uh
about because everyone else was going up
kind of you know short tight set right
and then norm went up and it is long
work around joke so i read you know in
the news uh it said that uh this guy
killed his family you know and uh chat
them up and put him in a duffle bag
because the devil told him to you know
how's that what if uh what if the devil
just took off his mask said hey it's me
bob
you know
but the [ __ ] part three was after he
goes oh bob i got my family here in a
duffel bag
oh that's one for you bob that's one for
you and i said what is this you know i
didn't know what it was right and uh
talk about a guy who just had balls of
steel the greatest yeah i saw him get
kicked out of the state of iowa
that was my favorite story was it you in
a tell no it was me that was a different
one oh i love that one do you tell one
oh oh boy i guess school's advice well
if you don't want to get chris kitten if
you don't understand you can tell you
can tell any norm story you want because
he was my white whale he was supposed to
come on the show i didn't know about his
health problem oh okay okay so whatever
you want to tell well
i love all those all right so the kitten
one that there's an io1 where it gets
kicked out it's pretty damn funny um
so we're doing the show
we're doing the show and pamela anderson
is on
and uh this is like 96 97 something like
that and
um
we're doing a twilight zone sketch
and while we're doing the toilet now
chris
and again at that time
we're all just trying to make it and i
totally understand not to
diminish chris at all
chris every time there was a hot chick
on he'd write scenes naturally to to
make out with them right
naturally
so
with that said
i'm sorry i don't mean to make your life
hard i'm sorry
[Laughter]
yeah that's how he probably reacted when
burt reynolds came in
so with that said so now we're um he
we're doing the sketches i've got a good
show i got a i got a go boy coming in i
got tommy lee tommy lee's telling me
stories that are horrifying about molly
cruz like dude yeah
so
we're about to do a sketch and no i
think chris got cut out pretty much of
everything so he's a little pissed and
norm
which by the way norm right up front as
soon as i got sent it live 1995. he took
the new cast
we were all new
um
and he goes hey
listen
don't put me in any of your gay sketches
all right
i do the update and if i'm going to be
in a sketchy means yeah don't put me in
your gay sketches
[Laughter]
gay not meaning homosexuality gay
meaning like is your sketch is stupid
right all right
don't put me in your gay sketch so
um
now you understand something
now we're doing a read-through all right
so on wednesdays you have to do a
read-through and norm is reading the uh
twilight zone sketch and he's not he's
eating a carrot he's a
imagine if you will another place in
time
and then
yeah he said he's just half-assing it
because he knows right he's seasoned he
knows this is gonna make it right so
he's not selling it
so it gets picked up and even i'm like
wow what
i don't know how wow he'd even try boom
okay so now we're at the now we're at
rehearsals and katan is non-stop guy
you're gonna you're gonna even try jesus
norm you don't even sound like the guy
and norm that's a really good chris
katan i never really thought of a good
kris katan impression until you did it
norm
never
like he'll just cut you down like yeah i
saw him say things to other cast members
like whoa
dude you don't care um
but he's not saying anything to to chris
which is
a little weird for me
like we're all i mean colin cousin
i don't know maybe he's uh i don't know
maybe he found god i don't know if i
don't
saying know and then now we're at the
dress show and katan's non-stop non-stop
god norm sketch man try to sell it it's
the only thing i'm in got it fine
now we do the dress show the dress show
sent it live the crowd's there
they film it god forbid something
happens they have something in the can
20 seconds
uh and katan starts like he doesn't even
sound like him he's horrible he's and
we're in the crowd the skit that
particular sketch is in the crowd so
everyone's listening and he's just
really norm
and i can't believe he's doing this in
front of a crowd right and i can't
believe that norm's not dishing it back
and then the dress the camera's on and
he's like yeah imagine if you will
and
you know another place in time like oh
[ __ ]
yeah this is a sketch i'm not going to
be in he just half-assed it right
now in between the shows
you got to go in lauren's office to see
what made it
it made it not only did the sketch make
it but it's like before update yeah and
to get in before update that's the
golden that's right that's the shot
now we're about to go live
one minute jim brewer molly shannon uh
you know chris katan
nor mcdonald pamela anderson please get
on the set we're gonna set it we're
gonna make up
and i'm sitting like what
what is going to go down right and katan
starts again
that's english oh my god norm
and we're live this time you can't even
try oh my god pamela you're so hot
you're so sexy you're so beautiful i
love you oh my god
if tommy lee ever drove 30 seconds oh my
god normally got 30 seconds even
20 seconds and i'm looking at norm
because in my mind at that time if that
was me i would have knocked him out
right i would have went violent yeah and
they go 15 seconds
and norm's smoking a cigarette and he
goes because yeah why do you just tell
everyone you're gay
because that's why you're so angry
because you're just doing a closet and
the minute you say you're gay no one
cares it's like you're gay but that's
only real 10 seconds every hat chick
that comes in here you want to like eat
a rat you make a kiss man but it's
because you're gay just say you're gay
five seconds
and and he's like
no wait that three seconds just to me
you're
just let it out get that
we're live and norm turns goes imagine
if you will
[Applause]
he
murders yeah and i could all you see to
this day
if you watch that show and that sketch
you'll see my shoulders doing this
because i'm uncontrollably laughing at
what just went down it was one of the
forget the la those are the mo i have so
many moments like that on snl that were
so much better than the real life stuff
oh yeah
well that's kind of what podcasting is
now in this stuff is the stuff that you
wanted to met you're like oh if only
this had made air and that's now it can
yes dude my father so when i first got
saturday live i fly him up from florida
um he's he's already pissed because he
brought a case of busch light
from this is pre-911 he bought it for
like eight dollars he's all excited he's
gonna go sign it live and my father oh
yeah my kids on television he's on
saturday he's crushing at the elks club
with these stories crush it so now i
bring him up
and uh it's the first show of sunday
live and i get cut yeah and whatever who
care i don't care i know i got a bunch
of more shows
i'm contracted for nine episodes
my dad's world war ii vet garbage
garbage man sanitate he would never say
garbage he was too embarrassed and i
said dad
don't ever be embarrassed what you are
man dude i look up to you as a man so
he'd always say ah sanitation
so
we go to snl and he's non-stop uh what
why why is your sk this show sucked
why'd you sketch us
why your sketch got cut this show sucks
who runs the show it sucks my dad it's
okay i'm gonna be on many many other
shows now it's the after show i'm you
know drank i'm getting high with blues
traveler
i'm
i made it right this is the greatest
thing ever we're about to leave it's
probably about three four in the morning
dad i want you to say hello to lauren
michaels
he goes lauren
what is
that jewish
where's lauren
ty what lauren english i said that
what
who's asking what
come say a little lauren my father he
wasn't but that's what he is so uh
we meet lauren
my hand to god i am not exaggerating
this
i go lauren do you mind i meet my dad
i'd love to meet your father
i go
dad this is lauren lauren
this is james my dad
and no no your son's talented my dad
goes
my hand to god he goes you know i flew
up from florida to see his show
sucked
what happened jimmy's sketch got cut
shut sucked
lord
holy sh
lauren lauren was a pro he goes well
next week cherry chase already inquired
he goes next week who gives a [ __ ]
i mean what happened tonight because the
show sucked and lauren was like i love
that he wouldn't let him go no he was
trying to be he's trying to be courteous
because he's like no i want answers
what happened tonight
suck did you make these decisions
because you sucked i brought eight
dollars of bush lights
you suck none of that milwaukee
i sprung for it i went ape [ __ ]
dude and that
as embarrassed as i was as that moment
as time went on i couldn't believe what
a what a damn hero and a real man he was
yeah because that's your first episode
and greatest story i've heard of snl so
far
who
i don't think anyone's ever went up to
lauren michaels and said your show
sucked ever and you took him out it
sucked yeah dude
that's i love you
he's more like my you know we'll sit
down and talk to my dad before i have to
go after this but uh he has more stories
like that too just my dad is very
tactful about it my dad is you know he's
so likable he's nice he's charming and i
will tell you so when i grew up
he would find a way he could find your
weak point and cut you down so deeply in
a nice way where it doesn't really
matter what you were saying
like i think i said you know one time i
was a teenager once ever like ah i hate
you
you see something like yeah that cyst
isn't quite going down like you thought
it would on your nose is it
you know that kind of thing you're just
like oh my god this is my dad and he's
worse than any comic i've ever seen he
would just pick your weak point and i've
watched him get into it with executives
with i won't say the names but
politicians national level politicians
and their handlers here there is
something
with like maybe just being at that age
where you just decide i don't care i
don't give a sh and i think i started
that early on because i watched him and
i didn't realize i couldn't get away
with it i was like i'm gonna be like him
and i made a lot of enemies let me ask
you this before we go to the uh the mug
club exclusive and i think it's
cigarsdaily.com entering the promo code
crowder not an official sponsor but you
get 15 off it's a good cigar isn't it
yeah it was that's a little cigar too so
you don't have to worry if you want to
try one out this is a good good medium
strength cigar it's also swisher if
you're going yes there's also i don't
think they sell those yeah maybe they do
hey for the record i wish this was like
a nine hour show oh we're gonna we can
go as long as you want no no no we're
gonna talk about hollywood pedophiles on
the mud club thing we can't do that on
youtube uh
if you have to be let me ask you this
because you've done you've done so and
i'm not saying this to shine your ass
but you've done so much okay snl and
you've done this stuff with dave dave
chappelle and but you've also done these
specials so many specials and you've
sold out these huge theaters
and then now you're in this chapter
where you sort of
you know uh inadvertently became
controversial again for people who don't
know
go watch some of his commentary and
watch his specials and it's nothing that
should be offensive but to some people
it was
if you had to pick
considering how multi-faceted your
career has been
what would you want how would you want
to be remembered if people say jim
brewer is what would you want that to be
to be dead honest i'd rather
my kids
be
learned from me as uh that i was a hero
for them
and then i was a hero for my wife and
family as far as the rest of the world
um
i've always
i i feel like
90 percent of the time i put
a good human vibe out there
95 percent of the time
as far as what they remember i can't
control that
um
just
just doing the right thing that guy
always did his own thing that guy always
just
he stuck to the program his own program
but i'd rather see that more in my kids
to give them a little like what my dad
did for me yeah and my mom too and my
mom but i think you'll be that though
for also a lot of other people's kids
who don't necessarily have a dad i will
say this the way i see you is as someone
who again
can you hear me
you start singing amy grant songs
oh my gosh she's still around i think in
some capacity i always wanted i thought
i was going to marry her and i wanted to
suck face with her so bad yeah now
you're chris kitten oh amy grant's so
sexy what a suck face with amy graham
isn't she good looking i loved amy she
yeah she was she was cute but i will say
this uh i see you as an unwilling hero
an unwilling
uh an unwilling sort of i guess
ambassador the reason that so many
people came in and supported you
is because there aren't many people
saying what you're saying there are
talking heads who say it but they say
that every day and so it really
registered as genuine where you just
said i think this vaccine thing forcing
people it's it's a bridge too far
and sometimes the best sort of leaders
or ambassadors examples are those who
never really wanted like george
washington said i shouldn't be president
for that long they wanted him to stay
there and so i'm not shining your ass
but i'm just saying you're an example
for people who aren't just your kids are
most important but there are a lot of
kids out there you know like they say
comedy babies they're like mitch hedberg
babies there'll be a lot of jim brewer
babies in the next generation and i want
that i want to see more uh my favorite
saying in the world and i won't say who
said this quote only because they'll do
people judge
they'll be like who said that
and then they'll find whatever bad
whatever oh he looked at his penis when
he was six years old
whatever whatever they'll find to
i love the saying it changed this is one
of the things that changed my life
one person can change the whole world
for the better
as long as they don't give a damn who
takes the credit
and that was uh
that moment and just my friend larry's
like bro
just walk the walk let people say i like
the way that guy walks
trying to think about this he walks the
walk yeah you can talk talk all you want
walk
the walk yeah you want to be someone who
lived it and that is
and i will i'm gladly
taking that role as long it's it's it's
online with
where it should be whether it's god
whatever it is but uh i'm such a sort of
like you know wannabe detective i'm
trying to think of who the singer is i
figured it's not a singer or you said
the lyric the person who said it i know
who said it no you don't it's bill burr
dude you got to walk the walk right
it's bill burke
all right it's bruno verse where can
people go and find your tour dates
jim brewer.com jimbrew.com we're going
to go to mug club exclusive uh
thank you guys i'm looking at the wrong
camera here this is cast strength
bourbon i told you it'll it'll like
it'll hit you no no you're talking this
is your camera uh and uh we'll see you
tomorrow but this is gonna go extended
uh hollywood pedophiles youtube
you